this is a joint work with Barbara denman
who's a student at Ecole Polytechnique
who said me earlier this year and
Siddharth sattva T who's somewhere here
where is that oh there he is yeah so if
you have any hard questions you can ask
him for an easy when asked me please so
this builds on joint work with another
former student reimu and a bunch of my
colleagues so the outline of the talk is
I'm going to talk about what I consider
the traditional noisy pairwise
comparisons problem i'll talk about what
our problem is and i'll talk about
algorithm in the prior work that i
mentioned and what is new in this in
this talk so the traditional pairwise
noisy pairwise comparisons problem is
this so let's say you go to amazon's
website and sometimes they might show
you three cameras for example you're
searching for something else maybe
you're searching for cameras but they'll
just show you a bunch of cameras maybe
so amazon probably has like thousands of
cameras in its store and they show you a
sum of these cameras maybe three
sometimes even two and then let's say
perhaps you click on the middle one or
you buy the middle one year click on the
middle one and then you get Simas on get
some information about you this they
know that you like item two perhaps
better than item one and item 32 also
more than item three so the goal is to
infer information about user preferences
based on this limited amount of
information that you have so often it is
assumed that the reason people click on
particular item over another item is
that there is a nun some underlying
model so for the talk that i'm going to
give today the central bank model is not
that important for it just for
completeness i wanted to mention this so
there is something called the Bradley
Turing model that people use widely so
so each item is associated with what is
called a score theta and the probability
with which you pick you click on item I
over item J is proportional to e raised
to the power of theta okay and the goal
is to estimate the vector theta from the
pairwise comparison so people you show
these pairs of items too many
different people and then you you want
to infer sort of the rankings among the
among these among these camera so you
want to know who has the highest data
who has the second-highest data and so
on and one way to do this would be to
just estimate the theta itself directly
and so anyway so the information that
you have is in the form of matrix this
is this is important for what I'm going
to talk about later so for each user so
you have this matrix where if user if
the user if this user was shown items 1
and 2 then if there's a 1 here that
means the user preferred item 1 over
item too if there's a minus 1 here for
example this user preferred m / M minus
1 okay so i have this matrix and a 0
means that you don't have any data about
that position okay so based on this
information the goal is to estimate the
vectors data okay assuming that there is
some underlying model here and this is a
well-studied problem one of the earlier
papers from 12 years ago is x hunter who
showed that the solution to this
optimization problem is the maximum
likelihood solution to this problem and
more recently negahban oh and Dave of
Russia have come up with an improved
algorithm and I recently found out just
in the last two days that there is work
by a different show not the same shock
neha shah and Martin Wainwright on this
problem where they don't even make any
assumption like the Bradley Terry model
okay so it's a nonparametric estimate of
just the ordering of the items okay
the problem i am going to look at is a
bit different so i'm going to assume
that different types of users of
different score vectors so perhaps users
in the world are of two types or ten
types users of type one might like
camera one more than camera two more
than camera 3 whereas users of type 2
might like camera two more than camera
three more than camera one okay so each
user within a cluster has a different
Bradley Terry parameter okay so so so if
you want to think in terms of Bradley
Terry model although that's not
important for what I'm going to talk
about so you can you can think that each
user in each cluster users and they're
different in different clusters have
different Bradley Terry parameters so
they have different rankings that there
are of the various objects ok so the
regime we are interested in is where the
number of users and the number of items
is very large like an Amazon's case and
I'm going to assume the users are in our
clusters where r is some constant
although I think you can probably let it
grow slowly with respect to n RM and as
I mentioned here the model now in
addition to the data being a function of
the object it also is a function of the
cluster that a user belongs to ok and
you want the gold this problem is to
make inferences where the probability
with which a pair of items is shown to a
user is very very small ok so so you
don't get to see all the objects that
mean you might go to Amazon's website a
few times a year and then you get to see
a few pairs of items so the idea is to
can you infer the information that you
want from just a few pair from from from
giving your peripheral amazon collecting
preferences about just a few pairs of
items so in this matrix formulation now
again I have plus ones and minus ones
indicating so if the plus one here says
that I like this person likes one more
than two and this this minus one here
says this person likes 3 over 2 but now
there are for example there are two
clusters there could be our clusters
yeah you know the clusters or is your
job to find because yeah this is the
problem I just yeah this is how it is in
reality but you don't know and so you
have to infer the cluster so that is the
problem the problem is you given the
matrix and you have to figure out who
belongs to our cluster yeah
he automatically automatically but we
make some assumption on we assume that
the number of users in each cluster is
roughly equal but but that's for the
theory and then we have some simulations
with semi real data it's hard to get
pairwise comparisons data we take we
took movie lens data and sort of convert
it to pairwise comparison data and then
did some experiments but i'm not going
to show it here i'll be happy to talk
about it offline yeah yeah so the goal
is to infer this but you don't know you
don't know who belongs to our cluster
all you're giving us this matrix okay
problem clear
so we are interested in two questions of
course so first questions what is the
minimum is a fundamental limit to the
minimum number of samples that you need
so the minimum number so in this in this
matrix for example the zeros indicate
that you know this this pair of items
was never shown to this user me so the
zero indicates that so you want to have
you want to get an idea of how many
zeros can I have in this matrix and
still cluster the users correctly so
that's the lower bound and of course
what is really more important is that
you know what algorithm am I going to
use to achieve the slower partner and
I'm going to answer these questions in
the reverse orders first I'm going to
give you the algorithm then if i have
time the lower one is actually very
tribune okay first I'm going to talk
about an algorithm that we designed year
and a half or two years ago and that
that forms the nucleus of what I'm going
to talk about and then we have made a
substantial improvement to it at least
theoretically and which is which is the
main new result so the key idea is to
first take this matrix of pairwise
comparisons so suppose there are 4 items
okay and three users there are four
through four choose three pairs of items
two tickets show right and so if there
are thousand items then there are
thousand choose to pay as you can so it
becomes thousands becomes thousand
squares if there are 10,000 items and
that pairs number of pairs of items is
10,000 square so the number of columns
in this matrix is just exploding it's
giving much much larger than the number
of items and that leads to a lot of
noise so what we do is first convert
this matrix in the waters called and net
wins matrix so I'm converting a matrix
with em choose two columns to M columns
and the way I do it is that for each
item I just simply compute the total
number of times this user ranked item 1
over everybody else so for example this
user ranked item 1 over 2 and then
that's it so it's just one whereas to
for example was rated yes I mean you can
find where there's a total ok let's look
at let's look at item to item to was
ranked lower than item one here gross
ranked lower than item 3 here but was
ranked better than item for here
the net number of times item two one was
is is minus one ok so I'm converting a
matrix with end users and M choose two
columns of pairwise comparisons to an N
by M M matrix so this is the first step
and this is this leads to a tremendous
noise reduction so we try to do
clustering directly on this matrix it
gives very poor performance and then
what you do is first convert it to this
net wins ok don't be minus one plus yeah
I don't know why we chose this this
could be any number could be five minus
one but but the row sum will be equal to
0 right because if somebody wins and
somebody else's to lose the Rossum will
be 0 but it doesn't have to be mine this
will be plus 1 or minus ones but these
doesn't have don't have to be plus 1 so
minus your right
in the in the if you go back to the last
one on the left hand side huh why does
it have to be one minus one candidate
you could show multiple I the same item
multiple times to use it but right we
are in this I don't think that'll change
anything we're just assuming that you
just shown shown it once yeah it does
that that doesn't make a bit difference
here so I've already said this or the
basic idea of the net wins matrix is
that it takes the N by M choose to
matrix into an N by M matrix and this
actually has a tremendous noise
reduction you can you can think of it in
terms of increasing the snr or whatever
but essentially it makes the data less
noisy okay and then after this all we do
is spectral clustering it's pretty
straightforward so since there are our
clusters in the in the in the matrix if
you look at the expected net wins matrix
that only are independent rows so this
matrix will have if you know the
expected value of this matrix then it
will have are nonzero singular values
but what we have is a noisy version of
it so so it'll have our singular values
for example if RS 10 left n singular
values that are large and the rest will
be small and then you take the original
matrix set X all but the first RF them
this is something spectral clustering
that many of you probably know just set
the rest of them the rest of the value
is equal to 0 secular values equal to 0
and then do clustering on the resulting
matrix okay the main result in the
previous paper is that if the number of
pairwise comparisons per user is r
squared log cube and then all but k over
and fraction of the users are miss
clustered correctly so positive yeah
we're just assuming there are clusters
in the in the in the in the yeah so and
you can you can see how many clusters
that are by just looking at the number
of singular values you'll see a phase
transition you'll have a lot of singular
values that are larger and suddenly
they'll be bunched are very small yeah
the movie lens data there was three or
four clusters how much four clusters
yeah I could clearly see a sharp
transition so the main result in the
previous paper was the number of
pairwise comparisons that you need for
each user is R squared log cube of N and
if you have this many pairwise
comparisons then all but k / frac a log
in fraction of the users are miss miss
cluster or at most K over log and users
are miss clustered with high probability
a positive spin on this is to say that
this fraction of users that are miss
clustered goes to 0 but it goes to 0 or
trait 1 over log in which is very very
slow so some K some constant K is what I
mean yeah yeah so fast sorry and and on
the other hand if you don't want any
users to be Miss clustered at all so you
want to classic luster all users
correctly then suddenly using the
algorithm that I just described at least
theoretically the number of comparisons
that you need number of pairwise
comparisons that you need per user is
actually proportional to the total
number of users so you need a huge
number of pairwise comparisons which is
totally unrealistic and the goal is can
you prove that perfect clustering is
possible with far fewer comparisons than
this our new result doesn't have this
end here just quite spectacular so you
just get rid of the N and doing by
adding one more key step to the process
okay
so the key step was inspired by a paper
by bamboo from 2014 on community
detection which is a somewhat of a
different problem here the one thing
sometimes this term pairwise comparison
can be confusing people often assume
that I'm comparing users directly I'm
not comparing users directly each user
is giving a bunch of pairwise
comparisons about items so all I have
what each user is some metadata so I
don't have direct comparison between
users so whereas in the community
detection problem if you know there's a
graph and users within the same cluster
have a higher probability of forming an
edge amongst themselves and users across
clusters have a lower probability
performing it just amongst them so
there's a direct so there is an edge or
a lack of an edge between every pair of
nodes I don't have any such information
here but nevertheless there is an
interesting idea in this paper that that
we that we sort of use in our in our in
our problem the idea is very simple so
all you do is you split the items
suppose there are thousand cameras okay
you split them into groups of hundred so
I'm going to do use information about
100 cameras in the pairwise comparison
about those 100 cameras and then the
next hundred cameras and the next
hundred cameras and so on and I'm
actually throwing out a lot of
information so i'm not using pairwise
comparisons about the first group of
items in the second group of items this
is somewhat surprising and actually this
improves the answer and the basic idea
okay so i'll get to the why this works
later on if i have time and then what
you do is that you do clustering based
on this smaller amount of information
and then you group put pull the
information together and the way you
pull the information together is that
user one might be in cluster one in four
of the subsets of data and might be in
cluster two and three of the subsets of
data then you say that user one belongs
to cluster one ok so the idea is that
you do majority voting so I'll going to
go through the detail so basically the
idea is that you take the items split it
into smaller groups do clustering based
on the smaller set and then and then do
majority voting some sort of maybe can
be thought of as coding in some sense
okay so there is error in each little
data set of data items that you are
looking at but but when you do majority
voting across the entire set of data
items it
Lee produces the correct answer so
visually this is the algorithm so I have
in this example I have six items I'm
going to split the data into two parts
i'm going to only look at pairwise
comparisons between items 1 2 and 3 here
and pairwise comparisons between items
four five and six okay and then I do
what I said earlier so you just do the
net wins matrix for this net wins matrix
for this and then do spectral clustering
okay so items 1 3 & 4 might partition
the users there are items and users so
the partitions here refer to the users
the users are then clustered like this
so so each one of these items might
reveal a different clustering of the
users now the question is which one of
these to believe okay and first of all I
don't know how cluster 1 here a
partition a cluster 1 here how do I know
which cluster here is the same as this
cluster here so it's not even clear for
example this this this partition
consists of a certain number of clusters
is this partition consist of yet under
yet another set of clusters and this
partition might contain items three four
and five in the first cluster and this
partition might contain item four five
and six in the first cluster how do you
decide which cluster in the first
partition corresponds this which which
cluster in the second partition we just
simply do a majority vote again which is
something like in majority would you
look to see if this cluster overlaps the
most with this is this cluster then you
just say that the suppressors must be
must be related okay once you identify
so basically the idea is that ok so if
this part is confusing just assume that
basically the algorithm produces
clustering so there is some additional
step to make sure the clusters are the
clustering is consistent in some sense
but the next step is the key step so the
key step here is that if user you
belongs to this cluster this cluster of
this cluster in this cluster so you see
that user you belongs to cluster two in
three of the partitions and cluster one
in one of the partition so I'm just
going to use a majority vote okay I'm
just going to say that user you belongs
to cluster 2
okay so the algorithm is this again just
to summarize you take the cluster you
take the items partition them into L
sets where L is something that we
specify in the theorem and then for each
of this L sets do using information from
each of these items the items in the
first set and the items with else set
basically cluster the users ok cluster
the users based on this limited amount
of data and put the answer together by
just simply doing a majority vote ok so
so again if there are thousand items
what I do is and if l is 10 I look at
information about just the first first
hundred items in the second hundred
items in the third hundred items I do a
clustering of the users based on less
data than what I am given ok and then I
do a majority vote ok so I throw out
some data actually and I do a majority
vote and the result is that the previous
result was that you need n R squared log
log raised to the power of flight log is
the power of five and peaceful pairwise
comparisons per user to cluster all
users correctly with probability at
least one minus one over N and now this
n is gone here ok yeah I'm surprised
that there isn't some
dependence on some notion of how
different the users and different
clusters are I mean in some sense yeah
so I will I will specify that so exactly
very good very good point yeah yeah so
you need some assumptions for this
theorem to hold and since I have a few
minutes I'll just go through the proof
and I'll tell you exactly what
assumptions we make ok ok so the
assumptions we make is that the average
ranking the expected value of the rows
are sufficiently separated and this is
true for so we don't need the Bradley
theory model for our result but if you
assume that the model comes from a badly
to remodel where the Thetas are chosen
at random from some interval then it
just you can show that this condition is
satisfied with high probability yes so
that is a very good point so the the
basic idea is that the cluster should be
the first step is to argue that the
clusters are well separated either you
can make that assumption or you can
assume an underlying probabilistic model
under which this assumption holds with
high probability that is a first step ok
and then the next step was to show that
the rank our projection of each row is
actually close to the expected value
using some concentration inequalities
you can show that this happens with
again this happens with high probability
so basically here if you notice that the
rows are separated by order n and and
the noisy version after its projected
actually is only separated by log n so
these are sufficiently far well
separated and the idea is that if you
have enough number of measurements you
can get a bound on how well they are
separated ok so in the previous the
first version of the result we assume
that there you have enough measurements
and so they are very well separated and
then you get the answer directly so what
we do is here now we don't assume that
there are enough samples for them to be
well separated so while we are able to
show is that the probability of
misclassifying is Delta which doesn't go
to zero ok on the other hand once you do
split the items into elf sets and do a
majority voting then it's a
straightforward Chernoff bound argument
to show that the probability of mistrust
ring actually goes to zero so for this
you need to choose L which haven't
specified so far L has to be chose
this or a floggin okay yeah if you don't
have that separation assumption at the
beginning could you do something like
determine the number of clusters like
online together with this element
because it seems like we wanted to find
clusters that the notion of cluster
should exactly be that there's a
separation between clusters that is your
definition which we adaptively discover
correct number of clusters so in the
actual algorithm the way we determine
the clusters we just look at the
singular values and there is a sharp
transition actually so yeah at that
point we haven't tried to justify that
analytically but it's quite clear that
in the in the movie lens data for
example the fact that four clusters is
quite clear there's a bunch of singular
values that are large and then it just
suddenly drops to something very very
small you can see that there is a phase
transition there in the previous paper
we did something else we used what is
called people call it the elbow method
so basically you look at you assume that
there are two clusters three clusters
four clusters and see how much
improvement that you have and you're the
improvement in performance is dramatic
up to some point and then it starts
tailing off and then you assume that
that is where it is so yeah but those we
don't have theoretical guarantees on it
so the way the theory is right now is
that so we assume this but we also
justified in the sense that if you use
the Bradley to remodel and the Thetas
are picked at random from some uniform
distribution then is this a satisfied
type role that's the way we just define
yeah
so the question is that you know is this
how close is this to a lower bound the
lower bound is really very easy so if
you have two users from two different
clusters and neither of the users has
been shown any pair of items at all okay
then of course you cannot cluster you
can't tell whether these two users
belong to the same cluster oh they
belong to the different cluster and so
so then you can easily figure out the
probability with which I need to show a
pair of items to a user cannot be any
smaller than login / n square and what
did I say before
and and and you can you can so this is
within a poly log factor of the minimum
number so that okay so the number of
pairwise comparisons you need per user
is login / so sorry this is the
probability with which you need to show
a pair of items since there are n choose
two items so the number of pairwise
comparisons that you don't need to show
per user is of the order of log in and
our result here says that we the number
of pairwise comparisons for our our
algorithm is log power 5 and so it is
within a poly log factor of the optimal
okay is that clear
so that's the I'm just summarizing the
main result here so if more than our log
raised to the power of five and pairwise
comparisons per user available all users
are correct clustered correctly with
with probably at least one over n the
number of comparisons required is within
a poly log factor of the lower bound and
it's been asked twice I think the key
assumption you need is that the rose and
the expected matrix are well separated
which is the only place where we use the
Bradley theory model to justify the rest
of the results don't actually use the
Bradley Turing model Hall ok so there is
some related work the work that we use
the most is this paper by bamboo on the
stochastic black bloc model and
clustering in it and so so what I'm
saying in my paper in this paper is very
similar to what man boosts is in the
paper so basically he starts off with
spectral clustering and he says you
cannot prove the spectral clustering
actually work so he does this he does a
different kind of partitioning of the
data and then does something like a
majority boot in his paper also and he
shows that that works ok that achieves
some kind of a basic limit for when when
spectral clustering work but what is
unknown and that's also true for our
paper and I want to be clear about this
that it is not clear the second step is
needed if you do simulations it looks
like you can directly just do spectral
clustering and it works ok but
theoretically we are not able to prove
that just directly applying spectral
class drink to the used ok so the first
step is important so you have to first
form this thing called the net wins
matrix that is important but you can
directly do spectral clustering on the
net wins matrix and end it and it seems
to work in simulations but we are not
able to prove that that actually is
within the sample complexity of that is
within a poly log factor is not clear
yes
so this I didn't I didn't think that I
would have x or include I'm here so the
data is movie lens data so it's
impossible to get pairwise comparisons
data directly so what we do is that you
take actual numerical ratings that
people give and then we say that if if
you have rated a movie too and another
movie 3 then you're more likely if I
show you movies 2 and 3 then you're more
likely to rate this second movie higher
and then we make we make a sort of a
Bradley Terry kind of so we use those
twos and threes as the parameters of the
Bradley Terry model so it's sort of a
pseudo real data I don't know how to get
pairwise comparison state otherwise yeah
so we took the movie lines data and sort
of converted it to pairwise comparisons
yeah I have to apologize to everyone
bloom because it's the second time
you're sitting through the stock
unfortunately I just gave the stock two
months ago at another workshop so this
is my last slide so so we've presented
an algorithm to achieve perfect
clustering with with high probability
where where the information that you
need for clustering comes from this
metadata about about pairwise
comparisons so users are not directly
compared but they are compared through
this rankings that they provide to other
items and majority voting from spectral
clustering over different data
partitions this idea inspired by this
vandal paper is the one that at least
theoretically works the open question is
whether without doing that whether it
directly works is something that we
don't know yet and at least if you do
that we can show that we get within a
poly log factor of the sample complexity
lower bound that's it thank
listen you should be fair that so you're
losing some information by constructing
the distance matrix and this part is
allowing you to retrieve as all that
information and which is giving you this
I think the net wins matrix that that is
actually important I don't think they're
losing information actually that is more
like an S on our site so there is a it
is actually so if you want to estimate a
high dimensional random vector often you
have to pry mean and you're in getting
information about a low dimensional
quantity projection can be useful and
that step is very much like a projection
so I don't think you're losing any
information there but but the later part
is somehow it is sort of like coding
that's the best way that I can describe
it so you're allowing some errors but
but but instead of directly estimating
something you're sort of getting
information about it from many different
perspectives and sort of putting it
together so it's sort of like coding
error correction codes but but I it's
not fully clear to me yeah it was
question are to be a constant it is it
just to have a separation so these are
all high probability results so there is
one minus one over and there's so many
so many places where it so nu you can
you can make so I think are something
like log and would work but I think then
the then the rate at which you're going
to zero will will be slower and you know
there is a lot of leeway here so if I if
I change some assumption then you know
it might it might lead to slower
convergence but if I want one minus one
over convergence there's a concentration
in equality at some point for example so
the many places where we use Union
bounds over clusters and so on so there
there you get a multiplication by our
and instead if it is a function of n
then you'll get a multiplication by
function of N and then you have to take
that into account yeah yeah did you say
this user
classif at the same size more or less
you said the more or less yeah so that's
the other yeah that's what yeah it's
more or less in the sense that as long
as they are all they all grow linearly
with respect to the total number of
users it's fine in theory but in the
simulations what we noticed it in the
movie lines data the four clusters are
of widely different sizes do you
remember what the cluster size is were
so there could be like factor five
difference for example again just
various bounds amenia yeah just it's a
Soyuz a concentration in equality to
show that the projection is actually
closer to expectation okay and then and
then then you have to say this about all
users I mean show you have to make sure
that you want to cluster all users
correctly every one of those every one
of those users must be closer to its
cluster average and the clusters have to
be roughly equal size for this to work
out yeah maybe in the interest of time
you take questions offline and fine